hi everyone welcome to biology professor  this is a quick review of the central  dogma of molecular biology often just  called the central dogma and it is that  stuff in that box right there it is the  idea that dna is the storage molecule of  all of our genetic information  dna in the process of transcription is  used as a template to make another  molecule called rna one of those types  of rna messenger rna or mrna is then a  template in the process of translation  to make protein so this central dogma  shows the direction of gene expression  in the cell how a cell gets functional  protein from its dna check out more of  my full-length study videos all about  biology by subscribing to biology  professor  and studying with me thanks for watching  bye